this week there was sad news for a true
American icon RadioShack the 94 year old
consumer electronics chain has filed for
bankruptcy protection half of its 4,000
stores will be turned into sprint
locations the others will be shut down
you know it's a rough day when 2,000 new
sprint locations is the happy part of a
sentence I'm not sure
short RadioShack has not been in great
shape in recent years but it's easy to
forget it wants ran ads like this the
best
that is a catchy song my friends if I
have left that on air they'd be the most
powerful company on earth today but the
death of Radio Shack in itself is not
surprising what is surprising is the
glib jokey tone with which its demise
has been discussed over the past year if
you have the name radio in your
corporate name that's probably not a
good sign of 2014 is Radio Shack doomed
to remain a punchline I actually like
Radio Shack I go there a few times a
year and I kind of like it I guess I'm
an old-school guy counter you must have
a very full junk drawer is all I can say
this is a dying 94 year old business at
this point it's like you're sitting
across from your grandfather at
Thanksgiving dinner saying you know I
don't really see the point of grandpa
fried in 2015 frankly I'm sort of
surprised he still exists Radio Shack
would be well within its rights to be a
little hurt at this level of disrespect
which is why we've prepared a farewell
message for them that they should feel
free to use for nearly a century
we at Radio Shack have proudly served
America Radio Shack providing you with
the highest quality home electronics at
the best prices and now sadly it's time
for us to say goodbye
and so we would like to offer this
special farewell message to America go
yourselves that's right take a 30 pack
of batteries and shove them directly up
your ass who sold your parents that
remote-controlled car you got for
Christmas in 1993 that you love so damn
much RadioShack that's who
in 1989 when you needed a cable to plug
your Nintendo into the TV who was there
for you that's right
RadioShack again and I'll look
at you laughing at a slow painful death
well laugh while you still can
because one day you two will
be obsolete one day you too will be left
behind in the wake of time ceaseless
onslaught and when that day comes no
that will be standing of your goddamn
grave laughing our asses are so on
America from all of us here at Radio
Shack goodbye and go to hell you filthy
animals
you